when I moved from Yale to NYU in 2008 I
came here because my husband actually is
in the city my wonderful Dean then Dean
Rickey Rivas said to me we want to give
you the Earl Warren professorship of
constitutional law I was very touched by
this and I knew where he's coming from
because Earl Warren is a great figure
both in constitutional law and in civil
rights law and those are my two research
areas but there was this really long
pause where I was agonizing over what to
say and then I thought you know you
write about advocacy based covering and
so you should not engage in advocacy
based covering and so I said I'm not
going to just let this go so I said to
him Rickey I'm really sorry but I can't
take that chair and he was completely
gobsmacked because I would have been the
inaugural chair holder he had already
you know worked out the indenture he'd
talked a donor so that does name this
chair could be named in this way for me
and it was just a really special series
of things that he had done so he said
why not and I said well as Attorney
General of California Earl Warren
interned individuals of Japanese descent
and I cannot I was pretty heavy with him
and that I quoted Audrey enriched to him
I said I cannot be honored by a person
who was so dishonored my people right
and so what he said was I absolutely
understand let me go off and think about
this for a few days and I'll get back to
you so four days later he calls back and
he says I have a new chair for you and I
said that's great what is it and he said
it's a chief justice or a warren
professorship of constitutional law and
there was another silence but this
science was qualitatively different and
so far as I thought you know one of us
is crazy I'm a phone call because what
difference could that possibly make just
adding the words chief justice in front
of this title that I had already
rejected so I said to my Dean repressing
a lot of responses what difference does
that make
and he had a great answer and his answer
was in the intervening four days I've
read a biography of Earl Warren and I've
learned that when he became Chief
Justice the you know
state Supreme Court he apologized for
his actions in a Japanese internment and
said that he regretted this more than
anything else that he had done in his
professional life and so wouldn't it be
great my Dean said to me if you could
have this chair that symbolized how far
an individual could travel over the
course of a single lifetime because Earl
Warren himself went from being that
attorney general who interned the
Japanese to this iconic Chief Justice
who wrote Brown versus Board of
Education and loving versus Virginia and
all the other cases that you teach so
passionately in your constitutional law
classes and so I said that Cherokee you
know I will take but imagine right if I
hadn't pushed through right imagine if I
just accepted the first chair and said
I'm just gonna engage an advocacy base
covering as an asian-american and take
the Earl Warren professorship that chair
which I could potentially have had for
the rest of my life would have just hung
around my neck like an albatross and
every time I used it I would have felt I
think a surge of kind of shame or at
least doubt right about whether or not I
had done the right thing you know given
that you know it had such deep emotional
salience for me right but now because I
pushed right and because we reached you
know a higher level of understanding
every time that name flashes up I think
about you know those words about how far
Earl Warren was able to travel over a
single lifetime and how you know that
really is my mission in life to take
people from the place that they are and
to bring them into a different place of
consciousness in a different place of of
human flourishing and so the chair has
an immensely deep resonance for me now
but we wouldn't have been able to get to
that extraordinarily positive outcome
that positive outcome even sounds like
an understatement that extraordinarily
kind of inspirational you know outcome
you know if I had decided that you know
I wasn't going to rock the boat and I
wasn't going to risk my own authenticity
in that moment that matter
you